yesterday senator lindsey graham he
toured what is the worsening border
conditions in the yuma sector in arizona
now where the bite administration is
trying to do damage control tonight
because get this according to a report
border agents they cleared out the only
overflow facility in the uma sector
ahead of senator graham's visit so ask
yourself why was the facility all of a
sudden cleared out the answer should be
obvious it's called another biden
cover-up because they don't want you to
see it just like they didn't want
cameras in the overcrowded cages in the
middle of a pandemic that they built and
where did the illegal immigrants inside
the facility go to did they get covert
tested did they get the vaccine mandate
or would they disperse to the rest of
the country and released into the
interior of the u.s was did they do
anything
they put impose any of the health
mandates that they're imposing on you on
them
anyway the biden open borders agenda
doesn't stop there as failed dhs
secretary mayorkus has ordered ice to
immediately stop any mass worksite
deportation raid in the administration's
latest efforts to gut and handcuff ice
here with reaction senator lindsey
graham how convenient that you're headed
to give an honest report to the american
people the yuma sector
uh and they cleaned everything out just
before you got there
uh it sounds a lot like when when you
and senator cruz and others
went to see the the biden cages in texas
well let me tell you what i saw one the
border patrol would like me to come down
every week because they finally get
somebody to help them
the border patrol the men and women the
border patrol are being asked to do the
impossible they're american patriots
that they deserve all of our
appreciation and thanks but they've been
abandoned by the biden administration
there were 5 000 people in this facility
made for 500 until i came when i got
there there was still a thousand so
between october of 2020 and october of
this year 2021 in the yuma sector alone
there's been a 1300
increase in illegal crossings in all of
2020 8 000 people are apprehended in the
uma sector as of uh the week i went
there as of a couple of days ago
114 000 people in the yuma sector alone
what you see in texas is moving to
arizona my friend
let me ask you this senator we're a
nation of laws or we're supposed to be
our laws are all predicated on that
great document known as our constitution
joe biden is not only not enforcing the
law but he's aiding and abetting the law
breaking by processing and not even
requiring they're requesting people to
show up not requiring
so my question is
does every other american get to pick
and choose what laws they want to obey
and not obey
well if you really were serious about
people coming into the country bringing
covet you know if you're going to travel
from germany to the united states you
have to be vaccinated and have a
negative test you had a hundred and
fourteen thousand people come into the
human sector alone since last october
nobody's being tested nobody's been
vaccinated they don't have the
capabilities
isn't that preferential treatment
for
immigrants
you
illegal
yeah it's stupid it's dangerous what i
saw that bothers me the most is another
9 11 in the making
there are 80 countries that they pick
people up from there are two terrorists
from yemen they caught just a few weeks
ago how easy would it be for an al qaeda
or isis cell to leave out afghanistan
and come through the southern border to
blend in with this group that
griff was talking about the border
patrol is doing the best they can but
they told me that the likelihood of a
terrorist attack coming from our
southern border grows by the day and
what you see in texas is moving to
arizona a 1300 percent increase in legal
crossings in the yuma sector in the last
few months why we changed the remaining
mexico policy now what my orcas did
today calling off all the raids of
worksite is going to be
another incentive for people to come
because the word is out you come you
claim asylum you never leave
the policy choices of biden are all over
the world now we had 40 000 brazilians
come through the yuma sector alone
headed for connecticut wearing designer
clothes and gucci bags this is not
economic migration anymore
people see an open america they take
advantage of us and it will be long
before terrorists gets in this crowd
unrelated questions so last week for two
months the republican party was united
in saying that they're not going to help
the democrats they're not involved in
the budget you've been pushed away that
you're not going to help raise the debt
ceiling then last tuesday one week ago
today
uh mitch mcconnell
folded your words we folded we came why
did 11 republicans for two months tell
the american people they were going to
do one thing and do another why why
didn't they keep their word what
well we should have we got ourselves in
a box but mitch sent a letter to
president biden said we'll never do this
again
that's encouraging to me they want to
spend the money throughout
why should we believe them this time
for two months the whole republican
party was saying where to united
yeah i feel confident that we're not
going to do this again if we do this
again we're going to shoot ourselves in
the head politically the democratic
party is ruining this country they're
putting our nation at risk the
republican party needs to stand strong i
went to the border and sarah went with
me what i saw broke my heart and i've
never been more worried about a
terrorist attack than i am right now the
men and women of the border patrol have
been abandoned by the abiding
administration i asked them do you see a
plan to change this
and they said no
do me a favor you might want to ask joe
if you ever get to see him maybe go
visit him in delaware and you might want
to ask him what his plan is to rescue
the americans he abandoned behind enemy
lines in afghanistan because he hasn't
talked about him in 40 days hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now